on a un très gros sujet c'est Stéphan
pazza puisque son avocate est avec nous
c'est la première fois qu'elle parle
l'avocate de Stéphane pazza c'est une
exclu incroyable maître Hélène plumet
est avec nous et on a des révélations de
fou sur cette affaire et elle viend nous
raconter l'histoire de Stéphane regardez
petit
recap depuis septembre dernier Stéphane
Plaza est accusé par plusieurs femmes de
violence physique et verbale mais aussi
de menace et d'humiliation Plata
agresseur M6
des accusations que l'agent immobilier
conteste et qu' impacte fortement il
vivrait caché en région entre Paris et
la région parisienne entre trois maisons
qu'il aurait et alors que la chaîne a
décidé de maintenir l'animateur à
l'antenne Stéphane Plaza a pu compter
sur le soutien d'ériic Antoine de Karine
l marchand mais aussi de son acolyte
l'architecte d'intérieur Sophie ferjan
il a beaucoup de défauts mais
certainement pas celui de lever la main
sur une femme plainte pour violence
conjugale contre Stéphane Plaza l'avocat
de l'animateur s'exprime en exclusivité
dans les
PMP merci d'être avec nous vraiment
merci à vous maître Hélène plumet d'être
avec nous je suis très heureux de vous
avoir ce soir et est-ce que vous pouvez
nous rappeler de quoi Stéphane Plazza
est accusé vous êtes l'avocate de
Stéphane alors en fait si vous permettez
je vais je vais je vais commencer au
début là vous vous commencez par la fin
et quand quand on connaît la chronologie
on on comprend mieux pour pourquoi on
l'accuse aujourd'hui de de ce
qu'onaccuse c'est d'illeurs que en fait
Stéphan Plaz ça fait déjà un an et demi
qui qu' se fait harceler alors ça a
commencé avec une une compagne une
excomagne qui s'est qui
euh qui a l'a qui a pensé qu'il le
trompait
qu'il et et elle a fouillli dans son
téléphone elle a trouvé des des numéros
elle a pris les numéros de plusieurs
femmes dans son téléphone et en fait
elle les a contacté et là il y a un peu
elle elle a commencé à divulguer des des
rumeurs sur lui autour de son entourage
professionnel amical il a déposé une
main courante donc c'était en novembre
2021 donc on est quand même quasiment il
y a 2 ans euh il l'a bloqué sur donc
suite à la main courante il l' bloqué
sur les réseaux il a bloqué sur le
téléphone elle a contacté donc d'autres
d'autres femmes il y en a une autre qui
a commencé également à à diffuser des
rumeurs toujours sur lui sur des des
prétendus MST si tu si tu si tu fréquen
V Plaza tu vas avoir plein de maladies
alors que qu'il a jamais eu une MS dans
sa vie donc elles elles ont pas trouvé
le le le bon le bon exemple eu on a moi
il faut savoir que ça fait 15 ans que
que je suis l'avocat de Stéphan Plazza
d'accord donc en fait je connais je le
connais bienoui voilà et j'ai vu toute
l'évolution parce que du coup il m'en a
il m'en avait parlé au début euh quand
quand il y a eu encore ces rumeurs on a
fait une mise en demeure d'avocat
d'avocat à à cette à cette femme et euh
su suite à ça en fait les les faux les
faux profils et les messages et les
harcèlements se sont multipliés et se
sont intensifiés à tel point que en en
juin 2020 2023 le 28 juin il a déposé
une plainte pour harcèlement et cyber
harcèlement contre X et en visant euh
ses trois euh ses trois excomagnes donc
dans la dans la chronologie ce qu'on
voit c'est que c'est lui qui a subi un
harcèlement euh et en fait à chaque fois
il s'est dit bon je vais pas répondre je
vais pas rebondir euh euh ça va se
calmer ça va s'arrêter elles vont euh
voilà elles vont euh ça va ça va ça va
s'arrêter tout seul en octobre 2022 il y
a public a sorti un article pour euh
dénoncer euh ça prétendu infidélité euh
on pense que elles ont vu que bon ça
avait pas eu plus d'effet que ça et donc
après c'est monté c'est monté cresendo
et surtout ce qui s'est passé c'est que
dans la chronologie encore en août 2023
il a demandé à une de ces de ces trois
femmes qui occupaient son un appartement
qui lui appartenait depuis 5 ans de de
lui restituer puis qu'il en avait besoin
et 3 semaines après il y a l'article
Médiapart qui est sorti d'accord comment
combiment il y a de plaines alors
aujourd'hui donc Stéphan Plaza lui a
déposé la plante pour euh pour
harcèlement si B harcèlement il y a une
enquête qui a été ouverte donc ça a été
vraiment pris au sérieux euh euh ensuite
il y a eu méia part quand en fait quand
l'article de medéiaapart est sorti nous
on a dit qu'on avait débosé une plainte
parce que normalement euh il y avait il
y a une enquête donc ça doit rester
secret surtout qu'il faut trouver les
faux profils il faut voir toutes les
toutes les personnes qui ont participé
et à la suite de ça elle elles auraiit
déposé parce que nous on sait pas çaf
peut-être que Gill Verdez on sait plus
que moi là-dessus mais en tout cas je je
nous on sait pas elles ont déposé elles
ont déposé des
plaintes et c'est que dans les journaux
qu'on sait qu'il y a une enquête qui a
été ouverte lui n'a pas été entendu
d'accord pour l'instant important de le
dire pour nos téléspectateur exactement
exactement pour l'instant il a pas été
entendu et de son de de son côté il y a
des femmes parce qu'en fait lui a été
harcelé mais beaucoup de personnes de
son entourage dès que des femmes proches
ou parfois une femme il suffisait qu'il
la rencontre une fois il y a il y a une
il y a une femme qui est venue à une
représentation au théâtre qui était la
la compagne de du d'une connaissance à
lui il a fait une photo un selfie qui
l'a posté elle a reçu des dizaines de
messages en disant tu es avec lui et là
est-ce qu'il t'a promis ça est-ce que tu
vas là elle elle a pas compris trop ce
qui se passait et donc là aujourd'hui il
y a trois plaintes en plus de la sienne
pour harcèlement et cyberhcèlement et
c'est quand même des faits qui sont
graves parce que il y en a une notamment
qui explique que quand elle a commencé à
bloquer les les les les personnes qui l'
contacté alors après c'est des faux
profils qui arrivent en fait à chaque
fois que à chaque fois qu'elle bloquait
il y avait de plus en plus de faux
profils de plus en plus de messages et
ils ont essayé ils ont appelé sur son
lieu de travail ils ont menacé d'appeler
son employeur il y en a une autre elle a
reçu plus de 100 plus de 150 messages
avec 14 faux profils il y en a encore
une autre ils ont pris une photo qui
était sur son sur son compte Instagram
et ils l'ont utilisé ils l'ont ils l'ont
utilisé en photo de profil donc il y
avait il y a quand même des choses très
graves et des méthodes très très graves
Gill oui à propos de ces ces trois
dernières plaintes là donc c'est trois
personnes de l'entourage de Stéphane
Plazza qui se disent harcelés qui ont
porté plaintte pour défendre Stéphane
Plazza est-ce que ça ça vient pas
attendez je vous coupe c'est pas pour
défendre Stéphan plazard elles ont
déposé plein parce qu'effec pour elle
parce que elle elle on elle l'ont très
mal vécu il y en a une qui est sous
antidépresseur l'autre qui a faill
perdre son travail enfin une autre qui
osait plus sortir de chez elle parce
qu'en fait quand on lit les messages on
voit qu'il y avait vraiment une traque
c'est-à-dire que à un moment donné il y
avait des photos prises en bas de chez
lui il y avait des photos enfin chaque
photo chaque personne chaque poste était
tagué était partagé est-ce que tu es là
est-ce que tu sais qui va inviter ce
soir est-ce que tu sais qui va avoir en
fait on on sentait qu'il y avait
vraiment une traque et c'est ça
d'ailleurs qui lui a fait de plus en
plus peur parce que il me disait je sais
pas où ça va s'arrêter je je je c'est
plus comment faire pour que ça s'arrête
il y a des noms qui
circulent vous avez vu les noms hein y a
des noms qui circulent sur ces trois
plaintes Gill on le
sait est-ce que vous vous pouvez me
confirmer les noms qui circulent ou pas
on parle d'Amandine Bourgeois Paola
ribéro et Sandra h alors ce que je peux
dire c'est que c'est quand on lit le
l'article de Médiapart il y a
effectivement des points communs avec
ces trois personnes des points communs
parce que c'est c'est les noms qui
sortent voilà ces trois jeunes femmes
qui c'est c'est ces jeunes femmes c'est
des c'est des ex de Stéphane ont des ex
ah ça je sais
pas juste une petite précision mare
parce que j'ai pas très bien compris
vous avez dit que votre client avait
donc déposé deux plaintes pour
harcèlement c'est ça non il a déposé une
plainte pour harcèlement et
cybercementlement d'accord oui et
d'après mes informations mais vous allez
peut-être me préciser les les
plaignantes n'ont n'ont rien reçu à ce
jour alors elles n'ont rien reçu à ce
jour parce qu'en fait ce cette plainte
elle nécessite un travail en fait
d'enquête elle est bloquée chez le
procureur alors non non elle est pas
bloquée non non non ah non cette plainte
elle est pourquoi elles n ont pas eu
vent de cette plainte parce qu'elle est
en cours et parce que comme comme il y a
des dizaines de faux profils il y a tout
un travail d'analyse de de l'OPJ pour
pour reconstituer et surtout ça passe
par Instagram à qui on demande à qui on
demande justement de retrouver les
personnes qui sont derrière les faux
profils en tout cas ça avance alors
Stéphan est dans quel état en ce moment
il est pas il est pas bien pas bien il
est pas bien ça commence à aller mieux
mais le le le mot qu'il a employé quand
quand l'article est sorti et qui
représente vraiment ce qu'il ressentait
a dit je suis anéanti ouais je suis
anéanti parce que en fait d' essayé de
leur parler de les appeler de du tout ah
non pas du tout ah non pas du tout non
pas du tout parce que là quand ça s'est
sorti il s'est dit mais il le dit encore
il est encore sous le choc en fait il
comprend pas encore comment comment
euh comment ça a pu arriver comment on
peut lui repocher ça pourquoi il porte
pas pleinte pour diffamation contre ces
femmes alors alors il on a déposé
plainte pour diffamation contre médiap
d'accord très bien d'accord on a déposé
plainte pour diffamation et injure
contre contre contre voici parce
qu'évidemment c'est un petit peu comme
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur le
plateau en ce qui vous concerne
c'estàdire que on prend un petit fait on
l'extrapole et puis après on esss après
moi ils ont dit que je mangeais des
hamburgers sur mon ya c'est pas vrai c
pas hamburger je mange C cher
VO les hamburger CER ça existe
exactement pas en mer malheureusement
oui mais en fait voilà c'est ça c'est
que c'est qu'après de chaque fait on a
extrapolé et que c'est comme si il
fallait trouver alors tout à coup c'est
f pl ça addicte au sexe alcool
substances illicites euh voilà c'est
c'est tout tout y est passé en fait
d'accord ouais les les les plaintes ont
les plantes ont transmis des messages à
meddiapart ces messages ont bien été
envoyés par Stéphane ou bien c'est ça
aussi c'est du c'est du bullshit alors
c'estes messages alors ces messages ont
été un petit peu on va dire un petit peu
trafiqués c'est-à-dire que quand on
regarde bien il y a l'épisode de la main
avec effectivement la la fracture c'est
c'est une chose qui s'est passée mais
c'est un accident en fait c'est vraiment
bon on sait tout ce que Stéphane est
dipraxique donc il sent pas toujours sa
force il est maladroit il est premier à
se blesser en le voit même sur les
tournages et en fait c'était lors d'une
dispute effectivement avec avec cette
compagne il il a voulu il a voulu sortir
il a attrapé la main pour passer et en
fait il a pas senti et en fait on voit
qu'il s'excuse la seule chose c'est que
la façon dont s'est fait dans le dans
l'article c'est que on vous montre les
doigts avec avec des messages mais en
fait si vous regardez bien et vous
pouvez le voir en relisant en relisant
l'article et en regardant les photos
c'est qu'on vous dit que ça s'est passé
le 25 avril 2022 et en fait après les
messages datent du 1er janvier 2023 et
en fait quand on a l'explication de de
le haut mon Dieu tout ça c'est parce que
elle lui reparle de cet événement alors
qu'ils sont plus ensemble et lui il fait
oh mon Dieu pour dire encore on revient
là-dessus alors qu'il s'est excusé
effectivement c'est un accident il s'est
excusé et c'est d'ailleurs le seul est
unique que événement qu'ell peuvent
qu'elles peuvent en qu'elle peut qu'elle
peut utiliser
dernière question maître récemment des
proches de Stéphan Plaza auraient été
harcelés par qui les proches de Stéphan
Plaza ont été harcelés dernièrement ah
mais des proches de Stéphan Plaz sont
harcelés depuis un an et demi non par
qui et ben alors par ces femmesl et
après comme je vous disait c'est par
l'utilisation de faux profil d'accord
donc VO c'est aujourd'hui il continue à
travailler à être à la télé euh oui il
continue à travailler parce qu'il y a eu
les il y a eu les enquêtes internes
alors ça c'est pareil on a entendu que
M6 avec l'argent qui rapporte donc de
toute façon il y aurait pas eu de il y
aurait pas eu de conséquences euh il y a
deux l'enquête interne s faite de deux
de deux manières par l'enquête parce que
quand j'explique une enquête interne qui
se fait dans une entreprise c'est pas la
police qui vient ou autre c'est c'est
c'est c'est une enquête qui se fait dans
l'entreprise où où les les les salariés
ou les personnes qui trava son end D6
n'a rien donné n'a rien donné parce
qu'elle a été alors elle a rien donné
attention c'était sérieux
ça été des HE al l'enquête M6 en tout
cas a rien donné qui justifie une
sanction en sachant qu'il y avait M6 et
qu' avait la société media one qui est
aussi une société productrice a PR un
avocat un cabinet d'avocat réputé pour
faire l'enquête donc c'était pas c'était
pas que M6 en interne à faire sa petite
soupe c'était vraiment les deux les
deux M6 avec son process interne et et
la société de production avec un cabinet
d'avocat et dans les deux cas
effectivement
il y avait rien de vous êtes confiante
ah bah complètement complètement parce
que moi j'ai j'ai des centaines de sms
et en fait ce qui est ce qui est
incroyable c'est que elles ont toujours
parlé effectivement
d'infidélité et bon ça c'est pas
pénalement
répréhensible mais il y avait jamais
jamais jamais jamais il y a pas un sms
il y a pas un mot où il dit ù elles
disent attention il est violent ou
attention tu risque pour ta vie ou
attention c'est juste voilà c'est
attention il peut-être euh il est avec
d'autres en même temps que toi merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous maîre
beaucoup merci à tous tout de suite
c'est que la vérité qui compte sur C H
merci